[Music]
nikki have you been
amazoning it up a lot i'm trying to cut
back on my amazon
i'm actually i don't know amazon be
giving me some real weird vibes lately
just the y'all don't be hearing about
how they treat the employee oh
i've been oh yeah but it's fast but it's
just
like super mega stupid like unfathomably
rich have you seen the girl that he's
dating yeah she's from like e news
or is there a new one well she just beca
she's the because of the record no but
the other one his ex-wife
became the world's richest woman based
off the stock when they
jumped she probably lost all now fourth
richest no she donated over
she almost gave like a billion dollars
to charities
good for her yeah she yeah but amazon
overall
i feel so conflicted because they're
such because they take over everything
because again too much news too much
news i feel bad going for
to whole foods now i'm like am i
contributing to this because i have to
open
up my app to get a discount i don't know
what was it oh yeah they own home
hopefully oh they also own twitch by the
way which i just found i found
god damn they own everything
yeah so when you go on twitch you can
give people if you have an amazon prime
membership a subscription
which basically pays them on your end
but did you guys hear about walmart
what about it walmart and microsoft
teamed up to try to buy tick-tock
they're trying to be a super team and
they didn't compete with amazon so
walmart's doing this huh
walmart's trying to do that so walmart
has a subscription-based service
[ __ ] america because they're because of
what trump did and was like banning
sales like we're not gonna send um
basically how
it's kind of complicated how like say
tesla and stuff they're able to sell
like personal data uh to foreign
countries
but only if america says it's okay but
because they can't do that they like cut
all ties of china china was like [ __ ]
you we're taking tick tock where you're
not even able to buy tik tok anymore
we gotta go look up because it changes
daily so it changes daily sometimes so
the last thing i heard is that walmart
was trying to compete with amazon with
an idea you didn't hear about microsoft
trying to buy it and also warmer imagine
that you have to walk in the store
like this microsoft went and they were
putting their bid in
and then walmart was like yo [ __ ] it
let's team up because they're trying to
take on amazon
so they're trying to team up together to
do it but
with that being said i like amazon i
don't think the pricing for it
every time is like super fair yeah i
think for what
pricing on some of the on some of the
items some of my items be way
priced wrong they're too cheap or too
too high too high well they have a
monopoly on a lot of stuff now so it's
kind of like
they don't have to be they don't have to
be fair
that and that's a big problem like what
mugs
okay let's okay so we were talking about
she's
she's so yeah she still leaves so they
have like
lease and those things on amazon do you
know how much that [ __ ] costs it's like
thirty nine dollars to forty nine to
fifty dollars
because it's so specific but you can
easily go
like say to a particular site and get it
there we've become so lazy
but amazon is making me start looking at
where these things actually come from
like oh maybe i'll go order it from this
place do i need it tomorrow
realistically no i can wait it's from
independent sellers that's why
right so they go and they make the price
so what they do is they go to like
walmart or target they scan the price to
see how much it is
yo the internet got all these secrets so
that's why when you see the stuff with
amazon
i'm like it's great i can get everything
i need in a quick amount of time but
do i need it this soon and could i get
it at a better price though
well you know what though it's all about
speed i actually got better like spread
over
speed over price who wants to wait i
hate waiting i got better price
and faster through amazon versus because
i was trying to buy stuff for my car
versus the car's website yeah but it
depends on what what it is like if i
could wait for the item i don't
like it is price yeah but then if it's
like one i can't get the item and two
i might if i'm going camping or whatever
right you need it like that
yeah amazon is convenient i'm not taking
away from amazon not being convenient i
just
don't do i i caught myself buying [ __ ]
that i didn't need
because i could get it like oh i got it
tomorrow and i just was spending for no
reason
but isn't it fun though that it is fun
having a package this
arrives and you're just like i love
christmas everybody you know what pissed
me off is having to break down those
damn boxes every time they came in
he pisses me off though is when they use
a gigantic box for a tiny little thing
i'm like how weird is that full it is an
option that you can wait to get all your
items i do that every time
and they still give it to me and that
like ridiculous cat
house you don't like surprises though
like you order things and it comes and
you're like
oh good lord i got a kazoo oh i did
order one
i haven't drunk ordered i haven't gone
online
i haven't i haven't drunk ordered i'm
like i get buyers for more it's like a
[ __ ] so i'm very are you good
with returning because i'm
hell no once i got it that's it yeah it
stays i don't think i've ever returned
anything in my life first off i don't go
to the post office like how am i
supposed to get this package to where it
needs to be
you have to find a box to put it in you
already broke down the other one i know
would like
to tape it back up and uh okay we're
already too lazy to go out and buy the
thing why would it
go out and return it but that but then
they offer it's like
uh like basically like 100 money back
guarantee but
they know you're not going to [ __ ]
return only nordstrom's i've returned
something to
nordstrom's is legit it's like unlimited
amount of time
okay anyway sorry sidetracker oh yeah
the story but i order from amazon
occasionally but i am trying to not
be so dependent on them when you order
though have you ever received an
item and been like what the [ __ ]
happened to this item yes
what happened the [ __ ] was just wrong oh
it was wrong it was just wrong color
it didn't look like the photo it was the
wrong item it was the
it was like [ __ ] i did not order this
mine's rarely wrong
rarely wrong yeah really they're really
accurate and really good with my stuff
i'm wrong you're wrong yeah for not
reading the measurements and stuff
yes people who get like the mini
versions of them they don't look at them
kind of where it's like i ordered an xl
and i'm like
i've gone in fat so i'm not an excellent
anymore but i get mad at them because
it's easier
oh you said they sent the wrong item
when it was you
who ordered the wrong size well this uh
furious
mother oh uh was very
she was pretty much on the verge of
vomiting when she
received her amazon package because
her daughter had asked her that uh she
needed
a water bottle to take to school so she
ordered one from amazon
a brand new water bottle and when she
received it
it came with water she thought there was
something
weird with it what is that uh is that a
liquid
there's liquid in there oh
no someone used it oh no can you guys
guess what kind of liquid this is b
somebody went peepee in the bottle oh
my pee pee in the bottle pee pee in the
bottle
pee pee in the bottle where's that from
i don't know is it genie in the bottle
oh no that would be i went pee pee in
the bottle oh baby
that would be that one
what do you mean this is a hit song dude
from lynch are you serious
you want to put me in your bottle stop
playing see somebody like that out there
we were like 11. no reason
i went pee pee in the bottle baby yeah
rub me the right way
that's probably it was an independent
seller then right or the or the driver
was the driver maybe
i got a [ __ ] but the driver came from
the open the box
to in order to pee in it and see what
effect it's from the factory it was a
factory yeah because then put it back
into the
way so how did she know it was peepees
because when she tried okay so she try
it no no so she facetimed a friend
to watch like to witness this
and so once uh she started opening it it
was like pressurized so it was really
hard why would you open it so then she
she finally opened it and as soon as she
opened this she got a whiff
of urine oh like there's she she gagged
like crazy she
that's what he went by matt's so much
she almost vomited no no
she vomited oh into the bottle and then
closer
and then sent it reach back i smell it i
gotta protect my nose i know
it's so i smell it right oh my god one
of those like
violating feelings you just feel
violated
wrong so would you be happy to just
receive a refund
[ __ ] no right i would sue
cause technically that's a felony
technically it is a felony they need to
find who dna that is
she could have called the police like
the dick girl yeah
think soup girl true well so i'm not
sure what the procedures are but this
does take place
in the uk and she did contact
amazon who then offered her a refund and
a
10 british pound voucher
it doesn't sound as good when his pounds
i know right that sounds so cheap quit
how about quid
what's quit i don't know that's another
one
i don't know if you're british let us
know what quit and pound the difference
yeah they do say quinn
yes i don't know it sounds like weird
ten quid is that correct i don't know
but anyway they told her to dispose of
it herself
what yeah and it's like
no like something more needs to happen i
don't know what needs to happen but
she needs to get all of his uh jeff
bezos's money
do you think it was someone that was
pissed off in the factory
that's there we go
uh you know like you know how they've
been overworking their workers right so
they're all pissed off and angry they're
like well you know what take this [ __ ]
and i'm [ __ ] quitting could be
quitting
[ __ ] your bundle [ __ ] um that's just
it's vile that yeah that would make you
feel uncomfortable whatever the hell
super sorrow is or super sparrow sparrow
oh yeah buy from them no because clearly
there's something [ __ ] up do you think
it was that company or do you think it
was an amazon worker
did it get you look did it get you it
was a [ __ ] bug on me
the same one why were you so scared then
it's because i didn't have wings and it
wasn't like i don't know
it was a new one it was on there i don't
know climbed up your leg
that's because you pinched his cousin
revenge
hey i was nice to your cousin i released
them into the wild
you did actually that was very nice of
you it came back it was just
did it bite you no but okay it freaked
me out it's okay
okay thank you okay do you think it was
that company or do you think it was an
amazon worker no it's probably the
company
i'm blaming the company i'm believing
that because you know there was this
whole thing in uk where the amazon
worker
like the drivers they were [ __ ] in
buckets in the truck
because they couldn't have time to like
take a piss or whatever to do all their
deliveries right yeah so they delivered
their [ __ ] in their buckets
i was talking to somebody that works at
amazon and they can't even be on their
phones or anything like while they're
driving and somebody sees they'll report
them
well you shouldn't be on your phone no
they're driving no no but there's like
but i'm saying it was like it sounded
kind of like ridiculous you ever hear
like oh i'm like checking the phone for
like directions or something like that
yeah just real quick just like yeah none
of that and like the rules are
different but again we i spoke about it
once and i had an immense amount of dms
about how
unhappy people were it was something
about like uh taking bathroom breaks you
get like punishment working there a lot
i i spoke about it because there's an
amazon close to where i live and
they were not very happy with the
treatment apparently they make a little
bit more than minimum wage like 16
an hour but the demands are very high so
but again um convenience we all know
that some people just like it but that
company
sparrow whatever you're buying we ain't
buying your bottles but
you got pee-pee bottles
[Music]
my